now bring you this tragic story that has
gripped not only Australia but now the
rest of the world almost two weeks ago a
family gathered for lunch in a small
town in rural Australia a day later four
people fell ill and within a week three
were dead it is suspected that a deadly
mushroom might have been served at the
meal and that might have played a part
here's what we know so far 48 year old
Erin Patterson here she is she invited
her former in-laws Gail and Don
Patterson plus Gail's sister and husband
Heather and Ian Wilkinson over for lunch
during the lunch she served a dish with
mushrooms that Erin claimed she bought
from a local store it turns out that
those mushrooms were not edible and
likely were death cat mushrooms which
are the most poisonous mushrooms in the
world now three of her four guests are
dead from suspected mushroom poisoning
with Mr Wilkinson fighting for his
lifestyle in hospital now Erin Patterson
has vehemently denied any wrong doing
joined Now by Australian foraging expert
Ingrid button also forensic pathologist
Dr Michael Barden who has worked on a
mushroom poisoning case himself and Sky
News Australia host Jenna Clark joins us
first of all Jenna if we could go to you
please we want to talk to you a little
bit about the details on this story I
know you've been tracking it closely
just just fill in an international
audience and what they need to know
yeah absolutely horrifying scenes in a
small town in rural Victoria Rosanna
it's about 150 kilometers southeast of
Melbourne so it's a very tight-knit
Community uh they all about four of them
went to lunch uh as you said a couple of
Sundays ago and three of them are now
dead I have an update uh this morning uh
Ian Wilkinson who is one of the
gentlemen who is in a critical condition
he now requires a liver transplant and
there's news just breaking that Erin
Patterson's estranged husband Simon his
two parents Don and Gail passed away
after that meal he was actually in an
induced coma about this time last year
after a suspected poisoning with an
issue with his small intestine The
Herald sun which is a local newspaper
here in Australia is reporting that
they've seen social media posts which
pertain to that so this story has got a
lot of legs left to go it does and just
one more thing Jenna um in terms of
Aaron's husband or a strange husband
partner and he also got sick last year
what what can you tell us about that
yeah so we have um apparently twice last
year he was quite ill he felt quite ill
and was in an induced coma for 16 days
and required acute surgery on his small
intestine but in a social media post
that a number of outlets have seen here
in Australia he did thank he's now a
strange wife Aaron for her support
during that time but then we have a
headline on the front of the Herald's
son today saying something like she
tried to poison me but it's important to
note that the Victorian forensic
detectives are saying that Ms Patterson
has been questioned she hasn't been
ruled out yet as a suspect and they've
also been to a local tip and they've
retrieved a dehydrator a food dehydrator
which they're now testing for death cuff
death cap mushrooms yeah I mean because
it must be restated here that obviously
investigations are still very much
ongoing it's actually almost like a lack
of information that is causing a lot of
speculation to fill the void as you have
you said that we did mention that um
Aaron the lady at the center of she's
denied this wrongdoing she was uh report
spoke to reports outside her house and
she was actually distraught that these
family-in-law members had died she
didn't mean to do it's nothing to do
with her she said let's take a listen to
that
and you guys don't have any respect for
no just that little clip there you can
see though that terribly stressed
obviously but tons of speculation here
but we'll have to wait and see the
outcome the investigation let's speak to
some experts then on this uh coming
first to You Ingrid in there in
Australia you've got up very early to
speak to us we do appreciate that you
are a foraging expert you specialize in
mushrooms you're based in Australia in
fact I believe in the state where this
is all taking place so how did you feel
when you heard this story because you're
aware of the dangers of mushrooms aren't
you
absolutely devastated to be honest and
us in the foraging Community have been
waiting for something like this for
quite some time it's really a atmosphere
of uh sort of bragging around a lot of
mushrooms and a lot of online
identification of incorrect mushrooms uh
so we're not obviously casting any blame
there but it is a really dangerous
activity to go for a day especially if
you don't know what you're doing and
death cap mushrooms are really easily
misidentified as three other mushrooms
so they are also responsible for nine
out of ten Global mushroom deaths so
this is not the first time this has
happened and let's hope it's the last
how easy is it to make a mistake when it
when foraging you know you educate
people on this um is it possible to make
an honest mistake
it is uh if you don't know what you're
doing as I said it can be a really
dangerous thing if you have attended one
of my educational workshops you wouldn't
have done so purely because we have
three simple rules regarding foraging
number one if in doubt live a doubt
number two white girls probably kills
and number three if it stains yellow or
green you should not be keen and death
cat mushrooms are those specific
mushrooms mentioned so if it's yellow or
green and has a tinge on the mushroom
that is a clear sign that it is not an
edible mushroom crikey I mean I don't
like mushrooms anyway so not at risk of
this but the thought of picking the
wrong one is terrifying Let's cross the
Dr Michael now to my understanding you
have worked on a mushroom toxicology
case before I just want to tell the
viewers as well some of the work you've
been involved in you chaired the panel
on reinvestigating the deaths of
President John F Kennedy Dr Martin
Luther King You've also been an expert
investigations on George Floyd Jeffrey
Epstein OJ Simpson among others and the
host of your own HBO autopsy just to
give our viewers a little sense of who
we're speaking to here tell us a little
bit about that mushroom case if you
wouldn't mind on how how you go about
investigating something like this yeah
when I was a chief medical examiner in
New York City we had a couple a
middle-aged couple who had gone foraging
uh in the woods for mushrooms as they
did
a number of times earlier and they
picked up this in in this case it was a
white mushroom but it can be green or
yellow or even Brown uh which turned out
to be the Amanita falloides
mushroom uh also called the destroying
angel
um and um uh the difficult part of it is
the toxicology doesn't usually help the
it's the history it's a Delayed Action
mushroom that is a person doesn't
feel the symptoms
liver damage kidney damage for maybe 12
hours 24 36 hours
when they become sick they become sick
with violent vomiting with bloody
diarrhea
and uh whatever the toxins are in the
body get metabolized so when they die
there isn't much uh chemicals to work
with and it's the history of eating the
mushrooms how they obtain the mushrooms
uh and uh that helps in determining
whether it's an accident or homicide or
suicide any of them could happen with
the deadly mushrooms with this mushroom
but what's interesting is is how
the prepare the mushrooms
obtain the mushrooms and
um
the symptoms the the chemicals the
poisons start damaging the liver and the
kidneys right away but it isn't
symptomatic for a day or so and that's
why it's so difficult to
find it from a chemical point of view
and as Jenna laid out to us the details
on this story the start you know
investigators still piecing together or
they they know but they're not telling
us yet with regard to how the mushrooms
were obtained if they were directly a
cause of the death of these people who
ate them and at what times I mean How
likely is it that they can get a clear
answer given the information that has
been made available that we know they've
got so far
well it would depend on where she
obtained the mushrooms it's unlikely
that she got it for the local store and
the only people who were injured were
the uh people the four people involved
and a part of it has already been
mentioned the treatment for the the
severe poisoning is a liver or kidney
transplants you know there's no uh
antidote for the for the toxins but it
depends on the detectives
finding where the mushrooms came from
whether it could have been foraging
accidental because these are beautiful
looking mushrooms for people who are
unfamiliar with what they look like they
look like prized mushrooms to us
non-phoiders like myself and they can
cause severe uh life-threatening deaths
and it's the most common mushroom I mean
I'm going to falluities in the United
States and India and in England in
Australia that causes death I actually
want to come back to Ingrid quickly and
ask then the likelihood you think of
whether it was possible this did get
into a store in the town where she lived
you took the words out of my mouth the
likelihood of that occurring is pretty
much impossible so first of all all
mushrooms supplied two shops will be
from the mushroom farm they are grown in
a different medium these particular
mushrooms death cap mushrooms emanator
pauloides require a host tree
particularly Oak
so the likelihood of them winding up for
sale if either needed to be through a uh
third party through some sort of
suspicious uh purchase or sale there we
have seen a lot of Facebook posts and
sales with people using other people's
photos and selling mushrooms that way so
it could have been from a disreputable
Source but the likelihood of you of
buying the incorrect mushroom from the
supermarket is nigh on Impossible I I
really strongly
would be absolutely shocked if that was
the case to be honest thank you both for
showing your expertise with us this
evening Jenna thank you for reporting
just quickly uh when can we expect
further updates do you know
uh probably within the next couple of
hours Rosanna we're expecting Victoria
Place to hold another press conference
wonderful thank you I'm sure we'll be
back to you when this story develops all
three of you thank you for joining us